hey guys Pete here this will be my
better call Saul season 5 episode 8
preview slash trailer breakdown they did
things a little bit different this week
they didn't release a sneak peak video
which they've done every week so far and
this trailer doesn't give a lot away
it's kind of exciting not necessarily
great for doing a trailer breakdown per
se but exciting just the same in that we
don't really know what's going to happen
episode 508 is titled bagman and the
episode description reads when a simple
errand for a client goes sideways Jimmy
is pushed to the limit Mike takes
measures to contain the wrath of the
cartel Lala gets an unexpected visitor
bagman is written by Gordon Smith who
wrote and directed namaste earlier in
this season he has a ton of writing
credits throughout the series including
two cannery which is one of my favorite
episodes overall this episode is also
directed by Vince Gilligan he's a
co-creator of the series he hasn't been
involved in the writing as much in
seasons 4 & 5 he still directs episodes
and works as an executive producer and
one of the insider podcasts he talks
about this and he says that this was the
most difficult thing he's ever directed
that's a paraphrase but something along
those lines the trailer opens in the
interview room at the jail Lalo looks
right at home with his feet up reading
the newspaper
Jimmy is there to talk to his client and
I imagine they're discussing him picking
up that 7 million dollars for the bail
from last episode Lalo says there are
people competitors of mine people who
want to keep me in here which probably
relates to Gus after that we have a shot
of Kim she says you got him bail
it looks like the idea of that and the
implications of Jimmy becoming a friend
of the cartel are starting to come into
focus for her she sort of straightens up
and really starts to consider what he
said of course this is in line with
Jimmy telling her what's going on with
him and before he met with Mike he had
no reason to believe he'd be able to get
Lalo bail this is the only shot of Kim
we see but it sort of sets the tone
of her learning what it means to be
Jimmy's wife we see a random shot of
someone opening a padlock that's
followed by this nice-looking shot of a
vehicle pulling into a warehouse with
armed guards at the entrance it's set up
so that the vehicle is reflected in a
pool of water which has a nice look to
it
I'm not sure what type of car this is or
who is supposed to belong to but the
armed guards are an obvious hint that
this is related to the cartel that's
followed by another shot of Lalo talking
to Jimmy in the jail he says hey you're
the right guy for this which is a
callback to when they first met in
Episode three which was titled the guy
for this it also suggests that Jimmy's
trying to wiggle out of picking up the
money apparently he doesn't want to be
the bagman after that we see Jimmy
adjusting his tie in the rear view
mirror of his car we don't see much here
but this is something that we saw more
in different trailers that are already
out there we see him in this same suit
standing next to his car out in the
desert waiting to meet someone and
there's a closing shot of the capable of
trailer where we see him looking down
inside of a well you would assume that
this is where Lalo sends him although
this could be something related to Mike
instead we really won't know until we
see it we see a windshield with bullet
holes being removed from a Cadillac we
can see blood on the top of the seat so
this is the same car we see later in the
overhead shot this is evidence of some
violence happening someone got shot up
inside this car but there aren't any
details that give away his car or blood
it actually is then we get a shot of a
counting room there are men who look
Mexican sitting at tables checking
organizing and counting money on a
massive scale again definitely cartel
related that cuts to a shot of money
being put into two duffel bags there are
two men taking cash from a big stash and
putting it into these bags from the look
of the suits I would guess these are the
cousins twin brothers Lionel and Marco
Salamanca it makes sense that they would
show up they're part of Lalo's family
and it's been a while since we've seen
them they're always dressed in these
sharkskin looking
suits so I don't think there's any doubt
that that's who this is after that we
see someone taking a Massachusetts
plates off the caddy probably the same
one with the blood on the seats and
throwing it in with a bunch of other
license plates we see only three
episodes left this season flash on the
screen which is really kind of sad and
then the trailer ends with that overhead
shot of the blood-stained seats so we're
gonna be seeing some cartel related
business from the description it says
when a simple errand for a client goes
sideways Jimmy is pushed to the limit I
don't know if you could consider picking
up seven million dollars as a simple
errand but I don't doubt that it would
be in Lala's interest to convince Jimmy
that it would be a simple errand that
going sideways has a lot of interesting
implications especially when we see this
car with the blood in the seats it's
saying that Jimmy has pushed to the
limit clearly he's going to find himself
in some kind of situation we don't see
Mike in the trailer at all but it says
that he takes measures to contain the
wrath of the cartel initially you would
think that maybe the wrath of the cartel
is related to Gus's Los Lunas location
of polios hermanos being bomb I mean
that should probably bring a lot of
attention to him and his businesses but
it's interesting to think that because
nachos working both sides because Saul
is being employed by them and he's being
guided by Mike there may be a move on
this money once Jimmy gets a hold of it
so that could be related to that another
thing here is this says Lala gets an
unexpected visitor which when I first
read that I was thinking that Mike might
go but as I watch this trailer over and
over again and I saw that scene with Kim
where she says you got him bail I almost
started to wonder if possibly she might
go to visit him making herself known to
him which would be a terrible idea which
you know I hope it doesn't happen that
way but it definitely crossed my mind
whenever we think about who the
unexpected visitor would be Gus isn't
likely to go visit someone like this in
jail there would be a record of it
another candidate would be Juan balsa
his
is a tribute to the sopranos character
Johnny Sack you know Johnny bag so that
name bag man might be related to him he
might come to talk to Lalo Hank or Gomi
could be a good candidate except for we
already know that showrunner Peter Gould
said they were only gonna appear in two
episodes so I doubt that they're going
to show up and then I've seen people
online saying maybe it would be Tuco but
I think Tuco would be in prison whereas
Lalo would still be in jail Tuco's been
given a sentence he should have been
classified and sent away to a
penitentiary Lalo is still awaiting
charges and all of that so he should be
in just like the County Jail the only
thing that's really certain is that he
probably still has the same plan that he
had for Jimmy to get this money and get
him out of jail does that involve him
meeting with the twins I would say
probably does that mean he has to go all
the way to Mexico I'm not really sure
but I have a feeling that this episode's
gonna play out as a complicated
action-packed kind of episode that moves
pretty quickly I can't remember for sure
and I couldn't find the quote but I feel
like this is the episode that they said
had a sequence in it that most resembles
what their original thoughts about what
the series might be before they started
was I think this will be a departure
where we see a different kind of episode
and if you think about it the stakes are
pretty high here Jimmy crossed the line
in the last episode we saw his struggle
as he scammed the system brought in the
fake family to pose as one day Guzman's
family in the US if he's carrying seven
million dollars no matter which way it
goes whether he pulls it off and gets
Lalo out or if something goes wrong he's
definitely gonna find himself involved
with the cartel on a different level
after this episode plays out another
idea that I've seen people throwing
around on Reddit is that since we see
this Cadillac here we might see the
origin of Jimmy's white caddy the lawyer
up one that we see him drive around and
Breaking Bad the one we see with the
blood is obviously a different car but
just the idea of seeing it people are
speculating that maybe the cartel will
give them this
one and that's how he ends up driving
around that car so I'm gonna leave it
there let me know in the comments what
you guys think's going on what do you
think Mike is up to what's he gonna be
doing that's going to contain the wrath
of the cartel
who's gonna visit Lalo where will Jimmy
find himself and do you think the
cousins will definitely show up please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already only three more episodes to go
it's pretty sad like I said but I'm here
for it thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon